we haven't seen
the cowboys operate at a high level
in more than a quarter of a century it's
now 26 years since they made it to the
nfc championship game but there's always
plenty of hype one of the focal points
of the hype this offseason second year
receiver cd lamb on thursday coach mike
mccarthy and lamb talked about the leap
that they expect from the first round
pick in 2021 here they are
i think you know cd is an excellent
example what you're looking for in your
second year players i i've always felt
uh with with a full off-season program
um
the age you know the
the second year player benefits the most
i've always felt when you're able to
have the the full nine weeks
and uh and i've always referred to it as
the second year jump i feel like the
jump is is definitely there i can't it's
it's all in the future whether to gauge
it uh
i'm excited about the future i can't
wait till the season and um but
definitely otas has been
it's been a a big plus for me in my
opinion
i see your bracelet what what what's the
what are we getting the popcorn ready
for on the
idea
uh
you saw it today
you saw it today you saw it today okay
anything else
get your
get your popcorn ready
oh get your popcorn ready hey you got to
send t.o a few bucks if you use his
catchphrase cd get your popcorn ready we
haven't heard that in a while from an
nfl receiver but
no reason to think this guy's not going
to continue to develop they have a great
core of receivers there in michael
gallup amari cooper and cd lamb tony
pollard getting some reps at receivers
so they can get their best guys on the
field because he's stuck behind ezekiel
and he's shown he can play at a high
level cowboys offense a lot of stuff to
be excited about peter it's the defense
that is going to keep people up at night
it's going to result in some high
scoring arena football league games for
that team this year i believe
look
we all know mike that last year the
reason that the cowboys
crashed and burned early is that their
defense did not take on
you know did not basically
take the defense that mike nolan was
coaching virtually and adopted as their
own and they were awful early in the
season and it all points many points
during the season and that's why to me
the most valuable person inside the
dallas cowboys this year is dan quinn
because
last year
they failed to take a new defense
learn it assimilate it and be and become
really good in that scheme
so now dan quinn comes in kind of the
uber aggressive dan quinn brings a
couple of his guys from atlanta to show
the way
but this is a team that training camp is
going to be absolutely vital to
and you know their their mini camp stuff
that they're doing right now you saw
yesterday i think it was yesterday in
practice that leighton van daresh is
flying all around the place and all
these guys are are you know going crazy
during mini camp and i think the reason
is very very simple they realize that
they blew it last year they absolutely
totally blew it last year for what would
have been a good enough offensive team
even with andy dalton so
mike mccarthy and dan quinn are laying
down the law and saying that's got to
change
the question is
if dak prescott's healthy all year long
will it matter how good or bad the
defense is because with dak and he was
on pace to have a ridiculous amount of
passing yards i mean it would have been
a record now it was through four games
he got injured in week five i believe
but if dax healthy just go out and ring
up the points and dare the other side to
to match it or beat it i just wonder you
know the big talking point that we
missed last year we all missed it was
that they're bringing in mike nolan
they're using a different defense with
guys who are suited to the last defense
now
are there enough guys from the defense
they were using before mike nolan to go
back to that seattle type of a defense
and still make it work
what does last year's experience do by
way of expunging
some of the players who were were able
to run the past defense and you have to
unlearn and relearn
i think that's part of this challenge
and as you say
in training camp that's where they're
going to get these guys reprogrammed to
do what's what needs to be done under
dan quinn and and peter look dan quinn's
never been
the defensive coordinator of an
offensive team he was the defensive
coordinator of a defensive team where
pete carroll was basically in charge and
then he took over as the head coach of
the falcons this is kind of a new thing
for him
where you know some of these offensive
coaches basically hand the keys to the
defense and it's all yours maybe he'll
thrive maybe this is exactly what he
needs
but this is new for him he has not done
this where he's been that guy who
basically runs the defense while the
offensive head coach is worrying about
that side of the ball
i think the big thing here mike is
whether he can take like i i think a
really important player on his defense
is going to be keanu neal because when
you look at the way keanu neil plays
okay
he is a guy who is a classic
big
safety to play down in the box and to
impact the game both in the run game and
the pass game i think he's a terrific
player a terrific ad for the dallas
cowboys the question is
how do they move him into the lineup is
he going to take some snaps away from
jalen smith let's say those are the kind
of things that are you know are to be
determined but i think the one other
thing mike you talk about
you know you sound like you almost take
for granted that that prescott is going
to come back this offense is going to be
great
i think that's like i do but here's what
i'm worried about here's what i'm
worried about on offense i'm worried
about an offensive line that two years
ago three years ago was far and away the
best in the league
and right now
i don't know how healthy that offensive
line can stay
you know with you know with smith and
collins at the book end tackles they
both had injury issues
can zach martin stay healthy the whole
year
will they be able to get good enough
play from
a rising player but we don't know that
much about him yet and conor williams
i i just
this used to be
you know a a granite wall up front
and now
we don't know exactly what it is and so
we'll see what that what that is and how
well they play but mike one of the
things about the great offensive line
they had is it allowed ezekiel elliott
to get 4.6 4.8 yards of carry in in many
games
you know and last year that one really
suffered
well and one of the things that sims
noticed after elliot held out in 2019
and i think it was still there last year
when elliott breaks into the open
he's not able
to gain as many yards in the clear as he
has in the past and that's part of it
too so when they pop a hole for you
it doesn't become a 50-yard run it's a
20-yard run so i think that that's
another factor and that that favors
getting tony pollard more involved and
the way they did the ezekiel contract
they're stuck frankly for the next
couple of years and all they can do is
hope that he can regain his past form
but i'll i'll concede the point that
having an offensive line that isn't as
good as it was a few years back is a
factor and it caused some to wonder what
they were going to do with that first
round pick they moved from 10 down to 12
they still could have gotten rashaan
slater before the chargers took him at
13. the tackle from northwestern they
opted for michael parsons instead to
shore up that defense but it wasn't a
ludicrous thought
that they may go offensive line because
that's how they built their offensive
line with first round picks and at some
point they're going to have to rebuild
that offensive line not with just
whoever they can find but they got to
start reinvesting first round picks in
round one or first round picks in the
offensive line excuse me in order to
make that offensive line what it needs
to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports